e
pour vivre heureux dit-on vivent cachés
durant de nombreuses années les
naturistes semblait avoir repris à leur
compte ce vieil adage il se retrouvait
dans des camps à l'abri des regards
indiscrets
cette époque paraît révolu bien que le
mlf soit étranger à cet état de fait nos
campagnes avides de libération se
promène désormais laisse un nul sur les
bords des piscines parisiennes comme sur
les plages de la côte d'azur de bretagne
et même de corse la plage de lomé en
balagne est devenu en effet cet été le
haut-lieu du naturisme sauvage mais
cette invasion n'a pas été du goût de la
population et le maire monsieur ceccaldi
s'est fait le porte parole de la ligne à
sion de ses administrés
les gens sont tous choqués je content
que moi ma population est choquée autant
que moi que des gens sur notre littoral
puisse se dévêtir totalement et faire
celui du ludisme intégral comme ça comme
ils l'entendent
alors que sur le littoral sur le ban de
la commune il n'y a pas de camps de
naturistes manège autorisée il s'agit de
la population sédentaire de vos
électeurs
il s'agit de la population devant de mon
village et même de mes parents je suis
sûr que tous partagent partagent mon
sentiment sur ce sur ce
on a su ce problème fait assez ridicule
moi je trouve que il faut laisser la
liberté de chacun et puis on retrouve
sur naturel du site toute la campagne et
sauvage c'est magnifique alors pourquoi
pas être libres de tout mouvement de
tout ce que l'on veut tout ce que l'on
désire sont des vacances que l'on qu'on
les passe commande
[Musique]
vous savez nous sommes en corse et les
corses nous ne sommes pas quand même
comme le sucre le suédois par exemple où
les allemands les allemandes ont
tendance très peut-être beaucoup plus
facilement que nous si vous voulez à
exhiber leurs corps c'est une mode il
faut la suivre puis ça passera espérons
que ça ne passera pas trop tôt je crois
que nous en corse le corse est une île
nous avons encore conscience de
certaines valeurs n'a été dans les
tranchées
là il ya des gens comme ça
gendarmes sont arrivés nous aperçûmes la
route on veut absolument rien fait pas
mentir avec des fumeurs
voir quelque chose
plus jolie visant les voir une femme qui
ne porte pas de soutien gorge qui en
fait tu arrêtes la ligne du corps et
ensuite pour des raisons morales
disons que ça peut enlever certains
complexes aux enfants et ou pas c'est
finalement une poitrine quand même
quelque chose de naturel
ma femme est encore et c'est joli pour
pouvoir se le permettre mais une petite
question pas insidieusement fait que je
tiens à vous poser vos petites filles
par exemple ont des soutiens gorge alors
comment se fait t notes pour singer les
femmes qui par exemple pendant les
périodes d'hiver au porte effectivement
des soutiens gorge mais des choses comme
ça et veulent devenir des petites femmes
ça c'est normal
cette contradiction je l'accepté
volontiers mais ça c'est plutôt un
handicap les enfants qu'autre chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
même si le tas
[Musique]
petit
du temps
[Musique]
ouah